People want to know how do you make money online? And I'm here to tell you,
see the real way to make money online is to make how to make money online
videos. That's how you make money online. Confused. I know. Let me explain.
See if you watch people who know how to make money online, what are they doing?
Well, they're making how to make money online videos leading to the inexorable
conclusion that the only way to make money online is to make how to make money
online videos. It's basic math.
The best selling products are products about how to get rich quick, right?
And who wants to get rich quick it's people who don't know how to make money
online. Therefore,
the best niche for the best selling product is how to make money online videos,
which means only one thing that if you were watching how to make money online
videos, you're not learning to sell a product or hock a product,
or create a product. You are the product. This is because how to make money.
Online videos is a beautiful pyramid scheme. And if you're at the bottom,
you need to learn to get at the top.
And the way to get to the top is not watching how to make money online videos,
but it's learning how to make, how to make money online videos.
So this really isn't about how to make money online. It's a how to make,
how to make money online video.
So how do you make how to make money online videos? Answer's very simple.
You get a bunch of stock. Images of people make money online.
You give a little voiceover, you tell people some way to make money online.
That doesn't work. It doesn't really.
No matter what it is. The point is you click beta men, baby.
That is a payment that I got on PayPal for a literally just using Google
translate a hundred dollars in cash just in the first couple of hours.
You can get paid to write without being a professional. Yeah.
Got to get the clickbait, make a hundred dollars a day, make $500 a day,
help make $10,000 a day. That's how you make how to make money. Online videos.
True.
Enlightenment is realizing that the only way to make money online is to stop
watching how to make money online videos.
Because if you're watching how to make money online videos,
you're not creating how to make money on my videos.
And if you're not creating how to make money on videos,
you really know how to make money online. I don't know. Does that make sense?
It should. If not, let's recap,
the only way to make money online is to stop watching how to make money online
videos and instead create how to make money online videos for the people who
don't know how to make money online. Now you might be asking yourself,
how do you know?
They don't know how to make money online because they're watching videos on how
to make money online.
[Inaudible].